So we just saw the Android manifest
file for the first time and
even though it's an XML file,
it can be intimidating to look at
because it looks different
from the layout and
resource XML files that we've been used
to seeing in other parts of the app.
So I think it might be helpful to
provide you some context for this file.
So every app must have an Android
manifest.xml file with exactly that
name but luckily for us we don't
have to worry about creating one.
So this file is automatically generated
whenever we create a new
app in Android Studio.
You can think of this file as
a table of contents for your app.
Let me explain.
In a book like this, we have a table
of contents that helps summarize
what's contained inside the book.
Similarly, the manifest file
summarizes the important information
about the whole app in a single place.
When you install your app on a device,
the Android system
first looks at this file before it
runs any of the code on your app.
So, what is contained in this file?
>From the last exercise you notice that
all the activities to have to be listed
in the Android manifest file.
Well, this manifest also contains other
important information such as the Java
package name which is the app's unique
identifier, components of the app, for
example, the activity names, intents,
permissions for notifications or
using the camera, and also it help sets
the minimum Android API, which means
to specify which versions of the Android
platform the app is compatible on.
So in the Android manifest file for our
Miwok app, here's the package name and
these are the components of our app.
This points to the theme of our app,
this is where
the app theme from the styles.xml
file's applied to so that our app and
status bar will be brown, and
this is where our icon is specified.
In the all apps screen of our device,
we see a basket as the app icon for
our Miwok app.
Within the Miwok app,
we have five activities listed here.
Within the MainActivity tag, we also
see something called an intent filter.
Remember that an intent is a message
that requests some type of action to be
performed by another app.
In turn, apps can specify intent
filters to announce to other apps, hey,
I could receive a certain type of
intent and perform an action for you.
This intent filter with
the action main and
category launcher indicates that
this is an entry point into our app.
When a user taps on the Miwok app
icon in the device home screen,
Android will send
an intent to start our app.
This activity will receive that
intent and open up the screen.
We'll have a chance to practice
modifying the Android manifest.xml
later in this lesson but for
now let's go back to building our app.